a CBS News poll out this morning shows
president Trump's job approval rating is
at historic lows this comes as mr. Trump
closes in on his first 100 days 41% of
people approve the president's job
performance 53% disapprove the poll also
gives clues as to why his approval
rating is so low CBS News elections
director Anthony Sal Vaughn toe is here
Anthony good morning good morning
smartest political guy I know he knows
the numbers oh let's talk about this
because President Obama at this same
milestone was it 68% approval george w
bush was it 56% approval why the low
numbers for President Trump
it's partisanship we have not seen and
we've been doing these polls for 40
years now on president's partisan splits
as big as the one that we see now by
which I mean President Obama and then
President Bush before him would
typically get about a third of people
from the opposing party approving of
their job performance but Donald Trump
has ten percent of Democrats approving
of him and so you have to know that
context and that's why it's a big part
of why his numbers are so called so low
Republicans love him and everybody else
is keeping their dissident polls also
show that he would still get more
popular boat than Hillary Clinton and
she would be factored in that if the
election was run again his supporters
are still entirely with him in our
polling and other polling you see that
across the board in fact many of them
have told us this is what I voted for
they think he's changing Washington they
like the approach so in all of that his
base and his supporters are still rock
solid and they're not disappointed in
the least even if he hasn't made as much
progress as they would have liked so far
if they say well it's a process Anthony
to that end these numbers tend to shift
over the course of the presidency and
yet are we seeing something different
with this president do we expect him to
be pulling Democrats to his side of the
aisle in terms of support or vice-versa
do we expect a departure of his
supporters well most Americans say it's
too soon to judge at a hundred days
which is another clue that sometimes
Washington doesn't think the same way
Americans think right but but the folks
who say well we've already seen enough
for the Democrats and they still say
that they feel emotionally they feel
scared or concerned the same way they
did at the start of the term so to that
extent they
don't feel like he's reached out they
don't feel like he's giving them
anything to latch on to that reform and
an infrastructure will give them an
opportunity to reach out to Democrats it
very well might and look a hundred days
doesn't predict the future we have seen
in this polling and our polling
presidents go up and down of the course
of their terms in big swings so hundred
days maybe historically low now but we
would expect movement by the hundred day
mark President Bush had had his tax cuts
passed by the house Clinton had the
Family and Medical Leave Act Obama had
signed the stimulus and equal pay acts
if to Charlie's point if President Trump
gets a legislative victory do we see the
numbers usually bump up a bit yeah we
might
I mean look even people who say that
they support him and want everything
he's doing say that they he should work
with Congress say that he should cut
deals remember the sort of big picture
one of the reasons that they backed him
wasn't just to change Washington but
they saw him as a deal maker but they
also know that that process takes time
that it doesn't necessarily just take a
hundred days and that's what they tell
us so he's got it if he makes those
deals then yes that's delivering on a
big theme promise they always great to
have you here thanks charlie